[Music]  five years ago I thought I lost you  forever  there is no curse that could ever tear  me away from you will you marry me yes  [Music]  mistress I have a little bit of news  don't ruin my morning  never asked me to marry him no I wasn't  really asking nor was I love doesn't  always end well beasty trust me let us  prove you wrong you have done an  admirable job going against your own  nature to raise this child but now she  will finally get the love of a real  mother tonight I consider Elora  my what have you done we go home now  Aurora  Maleficent is a threat to everyone  because you are best potential  [Applause]  one can never be too careful  this isn't you  you do not know me  tell me what happened there was another  creature  you've spent years caring for a shoe  now it's time to care for your own  [Music]  you